You might have heard the uproar in March 2021
over the decision to stop publishing six Dr.
Seuss books for racially insensitive imagery.
While this may not be a tremendous loss to
literature, one of those books could claim
a notable linguistic accomplishment.
If I Ran the Zoo, published in 1950, contains
the first written instance of the word “nerd.”
When authors create words for a one-time usage,
they’re known as nonce words.
Though it kind of sounds like “nonsense,”
the word nonce is actually a cognate of “once,”
as in, words to be used only once.
However, sometimes these single-usage words
can pick up steam, becoming neologisms, terms
that are still new and limited to certain
fields.
And perhaps some of those will eventually
make their way into our shared vocabulary
as full-fledged words, becoming so common
that we totally forget their literary origins.
I’m Dr. Erica Brozovsky and this is Otherwords!
Okay, if we’re talking about authors creating
words, we have to address the 600 lb. gorilla,
the Bard himself, William Shakespeare.
At one time, he was credited with inventing
over 2,000 English words, though that number
has dwindled in recent years.
Turns out, he was such a prolific
writer that his works were just the first
place many scholars had seen these words,
but it’s likely many were already in common
usage at the time.
For instance, "dwindle" was first seen in
Henry IV Part 1.
Shakespeare’s lexical creativity was more
about finding new and ingenious ways to use
existing words.
He would combine them, giving us bedroom,
outbreak, and cold-blooded.
He would change nouns into verbs, so gossip
and elbow went from being things to actions
you could do.
And he was absolutely extravagant with prefixes
and suffixes, sprinkling un-’s and -able’s
all over the place.
Not all of his creations caught on, but he
churned out verbal innovations with such regularity,
it's not surprising that we still use many
today.
Well before Shakespeare, the English poet
Geoffrey Chaucer, famous for his Canterbury
Tales, wanted to describe the light, tremulous
call an encaged bird makes as it yearns for
freedom, and came up with the onomatopoeia
"twitter."
700 years later, we’re the encaged birds,
tweeting our takes into the void.
In 1667, John Milton published Paradise Lost,
an epic poem and origin story of the ultimate
arch-villain, Satan.
He envisioned Hell having a capital city,
which he named Pandemonium.
The meaning has shifted since then to describe
a state of chaos where all hell has broken
loose, but the original, literal definition
was “the place where all the demons lived.”
By the way, arch-villain is one of Shakespeare’s
creations.
A couple hundred years later, Sir Walter Scott
was writing his chivalric romance Ivanhoe,
considered a major influence on the modern
version of the Robin Hood story.
He wanted a new term for hired mercenaries--soldiers
without loyalty to any banner, whose lances
were free to fight for whoever could pay the
most.
So he called them freelancers, and the term
caught on to describe people who work job
to job for different clients.
It’s definitely more colorful than the lackluster
“contractor,” but still a weirdly violent
term for someone who designs corporate logos.
Oh, and lackluster?
Another one of Shakespeare’s.
Lewis Carroll’s poem Jabberwocky is a multitudinous
sea of nonce words.
Okay, Will, we get it.
Many were created by melding two existing
words together to get something that almost
sounds like a word you already know.
For instance, chortle is a combination of
chuckle and snort, and galumph was supposedly
a triumphant gallop.
Both of these words managed to transcend Wonderland’s
borders into the English dictionary.
I guess if you buy that many lottery tickets,
you’re gonna win something.
When preparing his 1840 volume, The Philosophy
of the Inductive Sciences, Reverend William
Whewell wanted a single word to refer to a
practitioner of the scientific method and
came up with "scientist."
Just think: if he had gone a different way,
we might be calling them sciencers or sciencesmiths, or...
Scientician!
Uh...
Speaking of scientists, when physicist Murray
Gell-Mann theorized the existence of subatomic
particles in 1964, he named them quarks, inspired
by a nonce word that James Joyce came up with
for his 1939 novel Finnegan's Wake.
Like most of Joyce’s writing, I have no
idea
what the original meaning was supposed to be.
In 1920, Karel Čapek wrote a science fiction
play about humanoid machines constructed to
perform manual tasks.
He borrowed a Czech term for forced labor,
and "robot" quickly left the world of science
fiction to describe real-life automated machines
that work for us.
On a related note, most people think that
"droid" originated in 1977’s Star Wars, but
its first appearance was actually in the 1952
short story
“Robots of the World! Arise!” by Mari Wolf.
I don’t know if this counts as a new word
though, since it’s really just a shortening
of android, which comes from the Greek for
“man-shaped.”
Also, Lucasfilm trademarked the term so if
another author wanted to use it, they’d
have to cough up some Republic credits for
it.
Moving from sci-fi to fantasy, J.R.R.
Tolkien used the word tween to describe the
period in a hobbit’s life between childhood
and adulthood, roughly 20 to 33.
Today, we use it to refer to pre-adolescence,
because of its similarity to “teen.”
Since teenager wasn’t really popularized
until the late 1950s, Tolkien was probably
just shortening “between,” or combining
it with “twenties.”
However, hobbits did live over a hundred years,
so maybe the definition hasn't changed that
much.
One more scientician for you!
In 1976’s The Selfish Gene, biologist Richard
Dawkins wanted to express how culture could
be shaped by a process not unlike natural
selection--that ideas and thoughts could survive
and replicate based on their fitness.
He needed a word for a unit of culture that
could spread, so he took the Greek word for
imitation and condensed it to sound like the
word “gene.”
Though now we mostly use this term to mean
visual jokes that you post online, it originally
meant any shareable idea, style or behavior,
from religious beliefs, to fashion trends,
to new words.
That means the word “meme” is a meme.
Like biological genetics, it can be very difficult
to discern why some nonce words survived and
spread while others didn’t.
Why did nerd become a household word, and
not its neighbors, preep, proo and nerkle?
Maybe it just sounds better, though some suspect
Seuss simply stumbled on a slang
for nut that was already becoming
popular.
It’s impossible to know today.
Yes, Will, you can take credit for "household word."
One thing is certain .
A single writer can coin a word, but they
can’t make it popular.
All of us, collectively, through our behavior
and interactions, get to decide what becomes
a real word and what stays literary nonce-sense.
But its first appearance was actually...
(laughs)
But it's first appea-- (laughs)
Ah, I gotta totally make sure I'm not crying. K.